Nhi trình đầu tư sây dựng 1 chăm nhà xin hoạt động kết hợp phòng chánh lũ tại các thôn buồn của vực
Cô phố trên địa bản tình được chình khai theo kể hải xù 2 hais sấu ngày 1 2 thằng xấu năm 2020,
hình phủ trong hais sấu quay bán nhân dân tình đáng lắm.
Giang cụ thể hoả chủ chương của đảng nhắn nước về tăng cường năng lực phòng chống thiên tay
thế hướng với bến đổi khi hổ đông thời hoàn thiện thống hạ tân có sở phục vụ lời sống nhân dân.
Theo kể hải, giá đợt một sẻ lột tư sây dựng 1 chăm nhà xin hoạt động kết hợp phòng chánh lũ tại
2 mấy giá phường trên địa bản tình mới tổn kinh vị một chăm bệnh mươi phải chiến xam sống tư thì đông.
Phương hán thiết kể với bà mỗi nhà, hủ hợp với phong tục văn hóa của mỗi điều phương.
Thế kể nhà các bà có 2 tân bổ chỉ đầy đủ công năng thiết yếu,
vừa bà đảm không ra phục phủ xin hoạt động đồng thường suyên, vừa đáp ứng yêu cầu làm nơi tránh chú ăn toàn khi xảy ra mưa lũ,
có sức xưa tán hơn 2 chăm người, các công trình được đầu tư theo gửng đa một tiêu,
phục vũ các hoạt động hội học xin hoạt bán hoạt động đồng.
Đông thời lần nơi sơ tán chú tránh ăn toàn trong người dân và phục vũ công tác chỉ vì kiểu hộ kiểu nạn,
tập kết bật tư vừa phẩm khi xảy ra thiết tài, mưa lũ,
tòn bổ một chăm công trình dự kiến xe phần thành chức ngày mấy lắm thành chiến,
sẵn sàng vừa vào sự dụng trước 1 mưa bà ẵn thành phần phần phần xam hay sấu,
phục vũ cộng đồng kư dân. Đây là dài pháp thiết thực,
nhằm nướng cao khả nắng phong trong thiết tài,
có phần giảm thiểu thiết hải về người và tài sản.
Đông thời hỗ trợ hiệu quả công tác quả lý nhả nước,
phát triển khi tài sáo hội và xe dựng nông thôn mới trên đề bán tình.
Vìm chìm khai xin trình đầu tư xe dựng nhà xin hoạt động đồng,
kết hợp phòng tránh lũ tại các thôn buồn của phố trên đề bán tình.
Không chỉ có phần nâng cao cơ xe hạ tân cấp đề phương,
mà quan thị hiện sự quan tâm của các quay chính quyền đề phương đối với đời sống nhân dân.
Nhất là tài khu vật còn nhiều khó khăn và thường suyên sự tắc lộn của thiền tài,
nhớn dịm này bán tổ chức là 2,5 phần qua tạng của các gia đình chính xe khổ ngèo của sã hòa thi.